Hello, my name is
Vladimir Grubišić
and I am an assistant
professor in the
Department of
Biomedical Sciences.
In this session,
I will be talking
on principles of
neurochemistry with
the emphasis on
neurotransmission.
The objectives of
this lecture are to
understand principles
of neurotransmission and
actions of key
neurotransmitters. You will
learn locations in
the brain of the key
neurotransmitters, so
where they are produced and
where they are released,
and how they act.
Another objective is
to understand basic
principles of
neurotransmitter synthesis and
degradation, and how
these functions contribute
to the disorders of
the nervous system.
First, a quick
revision that the brain
has several different
cell types. neurons
here in yellow, glia
cells, endothelial
cells and many other
cell types that
all contribute
with their specific
functions to the overall
brain physiology.
This is a very simplified
overview and all
these cells have
different subtypes. For
example, there are
many different types of
neurons in the brain.
They have different
sizes and distinct
morphologies and they
have different effects
on the brain function.
Later in this session
we will be going
over excitatory and
inhibitory neurons and
basic classification
based on their key
neuron transmitters
that they are producing.
There are several
glial cell types
that support
neuronal functions.
Azocytes here in green
are closely associated
with blood vessels
and neurons. They
provide neurons with
the metabolic fuel and
clear waste left after
neuronal activity.
Oligodendrocytes
here in blue produce
myelin to grab
and insulate
neuronal axons
which enhances the
speed of action
potential traveling.
Microglia are
resident immune
cells in the brain
and essential for
immune responses
in the brain.
Endothelial cells here
in red are building
blocks of the brain
vasculature they make
the tube the most
inner part of the blood
vessels and form the
barrier between the
blood and the rest of
the brain tissue and you
will hear more about
this in another session
the other cell types
such as parasites
and epidemal cells are
important structural
and functional part
of the blood brain
barrier and ventricular
system respectively.
Other cells, mentioned
here, mediate
diverse brain
functions and become
ineffective in many
brain disorders.
The main concept
here I would like
you to learn is
that all cells
act as chemical
compartments and
there is clear division
of labor between
cell types in the
brain. For example,
People spend most
of the brain energy
on signaling, but
astrocytes do most
of the metabolic
work controlling the
composition of the
interstitial fluid.
They supply neurons
with energy substrates,
precursors for
biosynthesis,
recycling
neurotransmitters, and
clearing the
waste products.
Neurons cannot
survive with the
support from astrocytes
and all these
astrocytic functions
are essential
for proper
neuronal signaling.
I would like to
emphasize two of
these astrocytic
functions for
you to learn from
this session.
The first one is
called astrocytes
neuron lactate shuttle
and it shows that
major metabolic
fuel for neurons is
lactate that comes
from astrocytes.
The majority of
lactate generated in
astrocytes by
glycolysis is shuttled
to neurons via the
monocarboxylate
transporters and
gets used up in Krebs
cycle for their high
metabolic demands.
This pathway is
essential during
low blood glucose
levels when
the blood supply
is stopped,
for instance in ******.
Astrocytes then use
their glycogen stores
and supply the neurons
with metabolic fuel
in the form of
lactate. So this is the
lactate shuttle and
describes one-way trip
of lactate produced
in astrocytes into
neurons that use it
up for ATP production.
Another important
astrocytic function
is essential for neuron
transmission, and
it's called glutamate
or GABA glutamine
cycle. It shows
that glutamate or
GABA that are released
by neurons, they
get cleared up by
astrocytes through uptake
via excited to amino
acid transporters
or GABA transporters,
respectively.
In astrocytes, these
neuron transmitters are
converted into glutamine,
which gets released
and taken up by neurons,
and they convert
them into glutamate
or further down into
GABA. They package them
into vesicles and they
get released into
synaptic cleft to start
the cycle of neuron
transmission once again.
Let's talk more about
communication
between neurons.
This is an electron
micrograph of a part
of complex synaptic
arrangement called
lomerulus and it's
found in few regions
of the central
nervous system and for
us it's nicely
showing two kinds of
interneural communication
in one snapshot.
So on the left we see
two atritic spines
that are coupled by
gap junctions shown
here by these small
black arrows and this
is an example of
electrical synapse where
action potential
and associated ions
travel directly from
one neuron into another
through these gap
junctional channels
that connect the
cytoplasm of these cells
this kind of
communication is super
fast and without the
proper synaptic delay
On the upper
right side, we see
an image of an
action terminal
packaged with
synaptic vesicles.
Large arrowheads
point to the electron
-dense material that
makes the active zones
where the vesicles
are being released,
over here and over
here, and also where
the postsynaptic
densities are. Black
dots are immuno-gold
labeling for GABA,
identifying these
terminals as GABAergic.
And red arrowheads point
to synaptic vesicles.
You can see that
these vesicles are
clear, and they are
called clear vesicles.
And these kind of
vesicles are typical
for small molecule
neurotransmitters.
This is a chemical synapse
where communication
is mediated by
neurotransmitters.
In this scenario
neurotransmitters
are stored in vesicles.
These little
membrane envelop the
spheres of the
presynaptic terminals.
An action potential
comes to the
presynaptic nerve
terminal, opens
the voltage-gated
calcium channels,
which induce increase
in the local calcium
concentration and
trigger diffusion of the
vesicle membrane with
the cell membrane.
Neuron transmitters
get released into this
narrow space between
the presynaptic and
postsynaptic terminals
called synaptic cleft.
Then neuron transmitters
diffuse across
the synaptic cleft
and bind to the
receptors on the
postsynaptic terminal
causing different
actions through influx
of ions through
ionotropic channels
or generation of
second messengers
via metatropic receptors.
This kind of signaling
is characterized
by synaptic
delay because it
takes some time for
neurotransmitters
to diffuse across
the synaptic left,
but it also
amplifies the signal.
These kinds of
chemical synapses
are a predominant
kind of neuronal
communication
in the brain.
And right now
let's talk about
different kinds of
neurotransmitters.
Neurotransmitters
may be categorized
by their molecular
structure.
This cartoon
over here shows
some characteristics
of the small
molecular
neurotransmitters,
neuropeptides,
and gaseous transmitters
such as nitric oxide.
The most of neuron
transmitters
travel enterogradly,
so from
the presynaptic to
the postsynaptic
terminal as shown here,
and some neuron
transmitters travel in
the opposite direction
or retrogradly.
Gaseous neurotransmitters
such as nitric
oxide don't have
particular directionality
but rather diffuse
in all directions.
And we will hear more
about this special
neurotransmitter
later in this session.
Neuropeptides are
larger molecules made of
chains of several
amino acids. They are
synthesized in the cell
body where they get
packaged into large
electron-dense vesicles.
and then get transported
to the axon terminals.
Their action on
postsynaptic neurons is
mediated primarily by
metabotropic receptors.
Small molecule neuron
transmitters can be
further divided into
amines and amino acids
as in this table. They
are synthesized in
the axon terminals and
packaged into small
clear vesicles their
actions may be mediated
by both ionotropic and
metatropic receptors
and their signal is
then terminated by
enzymatic degradation
in the synaptic cleft
or and reuptake by
transporters on the
presynaptic membranes
where they get repackaged
into vesicles and
start the cycle again.
Please keep in mind that
many neurotransmitters
are not listed in
this table such
as other nucleotides
and nucleosides,
many other neuropeptides
and the cannabinoids
for instance as
a member of lipid
neurotransmitters and
many other bioactive
molecules and many
other categories.
Also keep in mind
that But real synapses
may release transmitters
from one or more
classes, and many
neuropeptides are co-released
with the non-peptide
neurotransmitters.
Here is a summary
of some key
differences between
the two, such as
the site of
synthesis and type of
vesicles as
previously mentioned.
Neuropeptides are also
usually synthesized
as a larger inactive
polypeptides that need
to be cleaned into
smaller active form.
These precursor
proteins usually
have pre and
or pro prefix.
For example,
pro-opiomelanocortin.
This is a precursor
peptide for three
different groups of
neuropeptides, just
as its name says.
Opio is for
beta-endorphin,
a member of an
opioid family.
Melanol is for melanocyte
-stimulating hormones.
And cortin is
for adenocorticotropic
hormone.
So one precursor
protein, pro-opio
-melanocortin, derives
several different
peptide neuron
transmitters and hormones.
Another important
distinction is
that actions of
neuropeptides are
mediated by
metabotropic receptors,
so their effects
are often delayed.
Neuropeptides also
linger longer in the
synaptic cleft,
and therefore their
actions are usually
longer than the small
molecule
neurotransmitters that are
quickly degraded in
the synaptic cleft and
taken up by the
presynaptic terminals.
This table also
reinforces the typical
life cycle of a
neurotransmitter that
goes from the synthesis
of a neurotransmitter
to the termination
of the signal.
Here it is once again.
Please note the steps
of the neurotransmitter
cycling from the
neurotransmitter
synthesis or production,
followed by storage or
packaging into vesicles,
release into the
synaptic cleft, and
interaction with the
postsynaptic receptors,
to finally termination
of the signal by
degradation, such as
the acetylcholine
degradation by
acetylcholinesterase, as
shown here in this image,
or reuptake to the
presynaptic terminal.
It is important to
know these steps and
their molecular mechanisms
because these are
the sites of action
for neurotoxins such as
botulinum toxin that
cleaves proteins
involved in vesicle
fusion in the presynaptic
terminal and release
of neurotransmitters or
insecticide poisoning
blocking the action
of acetylcholine
esterase and resulting in
the buildup of
acetylcholine at synapses.
Some disorders also
affect this cycle.
For example,
myasthenia gravis is
caused by antibodies
against the
acetylcholine receptors,
which block the normal
action of acetylcholine
in the neuromuscular
junctions and results
in muscle weakness.
and finally knowing
these steps allow
understanding of the key
actions of some drugs
for example L-DOPA is
dopamine precursor and
it's given to Parkinson
disease patients to
increase dopamine
production in dopamine
concentration in synapses
another example are
selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors or
SSRIs such as Prozac,
that block the
serotonin transporters
increasing the serotonin
levels at the synapses.
This schematic,
however, is missing an
important player that
plays a role in the
neurotransmitter
clearance and has many
important functions
in synapse regulation.
Astrocytic
processes make the
third active
part of synapses.
The three-partite synapse
is another important
concept that I would
like you to learn.
On the left, we have
an electron micrograph
showing a presynaptic
terminal over
here, filled with
small clear vesicles,
and postsynaptic
terminal over here with
postsynaptic
densities where the
neurotransmitter receptors
are and also other
plasma membrane
scaffolding proteins.
These neuronal
terminals are unwrapped
by the astrocytic
process in this image
pseudocolored in
green and are forming
altogether the three
part-type synapse.
On the right is a
cartoon summarizing what
I just said and further
illustrating that
this astrocytic process
in green is not only
providing a structural
support for the
synapse but is essential
for clearing potassium
ions that accumulate
after the neuronal
activity and also
in the uptake of the
synaptic transmitter
glutamate by the activity
of plasma membrane
glutamate transporters.
In addition,
neurotransmitter
release from presynaptic
terminals can
activate astrocytic
metabotropic receptors,
which then induce
release of calcium from
internal astrocytic
stores and in turn
trigger the release
of several neuroactive
compounds known
as glia transmitters
from these cells.
This mechanism of
glia transmission has
been confirmed to
mediate many important
functions in the brain
such as breathing,
learning and
memory, and sleep.
Peripheral glia cells
also contribute to
many other important
functions in the body,
but that topic is for
some other session.
Now actions of any
neurotransmitter
are determined
by the receptors.
And this is another key
concept of neuron
transmission.
Fast actions are
mediated by ionotropic
receptors. These
are ligand-gated ion
channels that come
in two basic flavors.
If they are permeable
for positive ions
or cations such as
sodium and calcium,
their activity is making
the neuronal membrane
more positive or
causing depolarization,
which is increasing
the probability of
the neuron to fire
an action potential.
Therefore, these receptors
are fast excitatory
receptors, and
glutamate is the key
excitatory neuron
transmitter in the brain.
Fast inhibition,
on the other hand,
is mediated by
ligand-gated anion
channels, so channels
that are permeable
for negative ions
such as chloride.
When opened, these
channels are making the
membrane more
negative or causing
hyperpolarization,
which is then reducing
the probability
of that neuron to fire
an action potential.
GABA is the key inhibitory
neurotransmitter
in the brain while
glycine is the main
inhibitory transmitter
in the spinal cord.
On the other hand,
metabotropic receptors
mediate generation of
second messengers that
ultimately affect ion
channel conductance,
which means they affect
the flow of ions
through these channels
and this is why these
receptors are causing
much slower but usually
longer responses and
can lead to either
excitation or inhibition.
Receptor proteins
can be expressed
selectively in some
cells and not in
others in the
same brain regions
which creates the
ability to set up
complex neuronal
circuits and produce
behaviors that
allow adaptability
now neurons in
general produce
and release
only one kind of
the main amine
or amino acid
and that's how they
are classified so
GABAergic neurons release
GABA and dopaminergic
neurons release
dopamine. These neurons
may still co-release
other neuropeptides or
ATP but they do
not release other
neurotransmitters from
this class so glutamatergic
neurons do not release
GABA or serotonin.
Neurochemically these
neurons are identified
by expression of the
key enzymes needed
for the neurotransmitter
biosynthesis
or by specific
transporters that are
required for their
packaging into vesicles.
For example, all
cholinergic neurons
express
cholinacetyltransferase, and all
glutamatergic neurons
can be identified
through the detection
of vesicular
glutamate transporter,
or VGLUT, which
transports glutamate
into synaptic vesicles
of the presynaptic
glutamatergic terminals.
Blucomaturgic and
then GABAergic neurons
are the most and the
second most abundant
neuron types in the
brain, and these
neurons are scattered
throughout the brain.
On the other hand,
amine neurotransmitter
releasing neurons
are clustered
together in specific
small areas of the
brain called nuclei.
These nuclei do not
have anything to do with
the cell nuclei, They
are anatomical nuclei
describing clustered
cell bodies of neurons
with similar
neurochemical composition.
For instance, substantia
***** is one of
those where
dopaminergic neurons are
clustered together,
and this area is
particularly affected
in Parkinson's disease.
We will go over these
key neurotransmitters
in the following slides.
And as you can see,
there is a striking
difference in the cell
body organization between
the amino acid and
amino neurotransmitter
-producing neurons.
The main excitatory
and inhibitory
neurotransmitters in
the brain are amino acid
transmitters glutamate
and GABA, respectively.
Glutamate is the
source of GABA
through conversion
of glutamate to
GABA by glutamic
acid decarboxylase.
Conversely, GABA is
converted to glutamate
via GABA transaminase.
So these two
neurotransmitters
represent the excitatory
and inhibitory
balance in the brain.
Let's first talk
about glutamate.
Glutamate is the
excitatory neurotransmitter
and is the most
prominent in the brain.
Therefore, drugs that
potentiate glutamatergic
signaling, such as
***, can lead to
epilepsy and seizures.
And on the other hand,
drugs such as ketamine
and alcohol, among
others, interfere
with the glutamatergic
signaling and cause
depressive effects by
decreasing excitation
and reducing activity,
generally throughout
the brain. There are
three types of ionotropic
and eight subtypes
of metabolotropic
glutamate receptors that
in turn determine the
action of glutamine.
AMPA and canate
receptors are the main
ionotropic receptors
mediating fast
excitatory signal because
these channels once
opened allow the
passage of positively
charged ions and
cause depolarization.
NMDA receptors are
different a little bit
closer look because
they act as co-incident
detectors which is
associated with memory
formation. These
receptors actually require
three situations to happen
in order to open the
channel. The first is
obviously binding of
glutamate or aspartate
for this reason but
aspartate is a less
potent agonist than
glutamate the second
requirement is binding of
coal ligands glycine
or d-serine and these
often come from
surrounding asfocytes even
with both ligand and
coal ligand attached to
the NND receptor the
channel pore is still
blocked by magnesium
ions and the polarization
is the third requirement
that kicks out
this magnesium and
finally opens the channel
and causing the
polarization this is why
these channels are called
coincidence detectors
it's because these
receptors require ligand
binding and the
polarization to happen
at the same time or
very close in time these
channels are associated
with the synaptic
plasticity changes during
learning and memory
there is a saying neurons
that fire together
wire together and it
talks about the increase
in synapse strength
when multiple signals
are input into
downstream neurons at the
same time. NMDA receptors
are the key mechanism
detecting these
multiple signals that
occur very close in
time and mediating the
changes in synaptic
plasticity and increasing
the strength of synapse
when this happens.
This is a way to
form new associations
between cellular
activity in the brain and
is associated with
learning and memory.
Changes to receptor
activity caused
by mutation of these
receptors associated
with different
neurological disorders
such as epilepsy,
schizophrenia,
and neurodevelopmental
disorders.
On the other hand,
GABA inhibits the
firing of neurons. GABA
opens channels that
allow passage of
negatively charged ions,
causes hyperparalization
of the downstream
neurons, which
makes that neuron less
likely to fire because
its member potential
is more negative.
Drugs such as ethanol
or benzodiazepines
enhance the activity
of GABA receptors.
They potentiate
inhibitory
signal in the brain.
Disorders such as
Huntington's disease
affect GABA production
in the striatum, the
brain center for
movement coordination,
And this loss of
inhibitory signaling or
this inhibition leads
to uncontrollable
movements in patients
with Huntington's
disease. These cells
express dopamine
receptors. And we will
talk about this once
again during dopamine
signaling system.
GABA-8 channels mediate
fast inhibition and
let's briefly talk
about their function.
These are GABA
-gated channels that
need two GABA
molecules to bind the
receptors, to open
the channel and
allow chloride
ions into the cell.
This in turn
decreases the membrane
potential and
reduces the chance
of action-potational
firing. In other
words, it inhibits
that neuron.
Now, we will move on
to AMI transmitters.
The second column is the
main neurotransmitter
at the neuromuscular
junction,
where it mediates
voluntary
contractions of
somatic muscles.
It is also one
of the principal
neurotransmitters in the
autonomic nervous system.
It is the parasympathetic
neurotransmitter,
but it is also
released at the
preganglionic nerves of
the sympathetic system,
and also in the
enteric nervous system,
it causes intestinal
smooth muscle
contraction and the gut
epithelial secretions.
Acetylcholine is
also produced in the
brain, and choline
acetyltransferase, here on
the top, is the
important biosynthesis
enzyme. It is usually
abbreviated as CHAD,
so all cholinergic
neurons are
CHAD-positive,
and that is one
way of identifying
these cells.
Below is another
important enzyme,
acetylcholinesterase,
that stops
acetylcholin signaling
in the synapse by
degrading it to
acetate and choline.
Choline is then
taken up by
the presynaptic
terminal for
another
neurotransmitter cycle.
Here is a nice summary
of what I've just
said. Acetylcholine is
synthesized in the nerve
terminals by CHAT
from choline and
acetylcoenzyme A. It gets
packaged into vesicles,
released with oncoming
action potential, and
acts on receptors on
the postsynaptic cell.
Cholinergic signaling
in the brain is
important for learning
and memory, and these
CHAT-positive cells
are decreased in
brains from Alzheimer's
disease patients.
It is thought that
decreased cholinergic
signaling is
contributing to the
disease, so a treatment
approach is to
increase acetylcholine,
and there are
FDA-approved drugs
to do exactly that
by blocking acetylcholine
degradation.
Acetylcholinesterase
is the key
enzyme to stop
the cholinergic
signaling, as we
mentioned already.
It is expressed in
the synaptic cleft,
where it converts
acetylcholin into
acetate and choline.
This enzyme is
the target of some
Alzheimer's disease
drugs in an attempt
to balance out the
degeneration of
cholinergic neurons.
Acetylcholinesterase
is also
a target for
organophosphate
insecticides and
nerve agents.
Poisoning is causing
overstimulation
of the cholinergic
receptors and causing
muscle spasms and
other symptoms
resulting from hyperactive
parasympathetic
systems such as
increased salivation,
lacrimation, and
intestinal motility and
diarrhea. These
parasympathetic signals are
mediated by muscarinic
receptors and can be
controlled by muscarinic
antagonist atropine.
In the brain,
acetylcholine is not widely
produced like glutamate
and GABA. There are
three primary groups
of cholinergic neurons,
those originating in
ventral areas of the
forebrain, such as
nucleus basalis, a nuclei
of the diagonal band
and medial septum.
Another location is
in the pons, and there
are also small interneurals
in the striatum,
which are not shown
in this schematic.
These small cholinergic
neurons in the
striatum are inhibited
by dopaminergic neurons
from Substantia *****,
and they are the
basis for the use of
muscarinic receptor
antagonists in treating
Parkinson's disease.
Neurons from the
nucleus basalis project
to large areas of
the cerebral cortex,
while septal and
diagonal band neurons
project largely to
the hippocampus.
These path phases
are important
in learning
and memory, and
degenerate in
Alzheimer's disease.
Therefore,
treatment of this
disorder involves
the use of
acetylcholinester
as inhibitors
in attempts to alleviate
this cholinergic deficit.
Neurons originating in
the dorsal tegmentum
of the pons project
to the thalamus and
basal forebrain and
have descending pathways
to the reticular
formation, cerebellum,
vestibular nuclei, and
cranial nerve nuclei.
they are involved
in arousal and REM
sleep it's important
to know the locations
of these nuclei because
****** or injury
to these areas can
cause loss of functions
that are specific
for these pathways
so learning and memory
for basal forebrain
pathways and arousal
and sleep for
mesopotamia pathways
all the Neurocholinergic
neurons are found in
a few small areas in
the brain. They project
widely, and their
actions are mediated
by the receptors.
And the image shows
their distribution
in the brain. We
can see that cortex
expresses both
nicotinic and
muscarinic receptors,
while certain brain
areas have more
specific expression.
We can see that most
of the brainstem
has muscarinic
receptors, and there are
few small areas
expressing only nicotinic
receptors such as
substantia *****,
locus ferulis,
and septum. These
differences will cause
different actions
of acetylcholine
in these areas.
Moving on to glatecholamine
neurotransmitters,
so dopamine,
noradrenaline or
norepinephrine and adrenaline
or epinephrine they
are produced in this
chain of chemical
reactions from
tyrosine all the way to
epinephrine it is
important to know this
biosynthesis pathway
because only cells that
produce catecholamines
express these keys
enzymes also this is
the basis for some
treatments such as l-dopa
is given to parkinson
disease patients
because it is dopamine
precursor and
increases the levels of
dopamine everywhere
and that relieves some
symptoms of this
neurodegenerative disease.
Equally important
is to know
the main degradation
pathways.
It is important to know
that catecholamines
are degraded by the
same kind of enzymes,
so drugs targeting
these enzymes
such as monoamine
oxidase inhibitors
for depression treatment
will affect the
levels of all of them
so monoamine oxidase
also degrades
serotomy and these can
lead to serious drug
interactions and we
will talk about it
later in this session
catecholamines are
released throughout
the brain but they
have very specific
areas where they
are produced within
the brain, just
like acetylcholine.
Catecholamines are
also produced by
other tissues outside
the brain as well.
In fact,
epinephrine is
produced by neurons of
the brainstem, but
mostly produced in the
adrenal glands and
serves as a hormone.
So, I already mentioned
that epaminergic
neurons project widely
in the brain. However,
their cell bodies
are primarily found
in three brain
locations, two in the
midbrain containing the
substantia ***** and
adjacent ventral
tegmental area and
the arcuate nucleus
of the hypothalamus.
Negrostriatal dopaminergic
neurons project
to striatum, so-called
nucleus and pitamen,
and are involved in
control of posture
and movement. These
neurons degenerate in
Parkinson's disease,
and drugs to treat
Parkinson stimulate
these pathways, such as
L-DOPA, increasing the
levels of dopamine.
The ventral tegmental
area neurons extend
to the cortex and
limbic system, and
they are referred
as mesocortical or
mesolimbic pathways,
respectively, and are
important for complex,
target-oriented
behaviors, including
psychotic behaviors.
So many antipsychotic
drugs work to
block or inhibit
these pathways. Those
neurons projecting
from the ventral
tegmental area to the
nucleus accumbens are
believed to be
involved in addiction.
Dopamine is also
synthesized by much shorter
neurons originating
in the arcuate nucleus
of the hypothalamus
and projecting to
pituitary into median
eminence and this pathway
is known as tubular
infidibular pathway.
These neurons regulate
anterior pituitary
function and decrease
prolactin secretion.
And some drugs
affecting dopamine
signaling also
perturb the system.
For example,
antipsychotics, particularly
the first
-generation ones,
often cause
hyperprolactinemia or
increase prolactin
levels in the blood.
The effects of
dopamine signaling
will depend again
on their receptors.
Here is the
map of dopamine
receptor distribution.
We can see that
dopaminergic neurons
also project widely
across the brain.
These receptors also have
specific patterns
of expression.
cortex and limbic
system have all kinds
of dopamine receptor
subtypes and these
are again controlling
addiction and
psychotic behaviors on
the other hand striatum
and hypothalamus have
a mix of specific
excitatory and
inhibitory receptors i
would like to turn
your attention to
striatum striatal
neurons are important for
coordinating movements
and i've already
mentioned how they are
involved in Parkinson's
disease affecting
cholinergic interneurons
in this area striatal
GABAergic neurons
die in Huntington's
disease and we
already talked about this
as well the Huntington's
is a neurodegenerative
disease that
targets striatum
particularly medium spiny
neurons expressing
these two receptors in
the initial state of
the disease and this
results in the imbalance
of dopaminergic
signaling and causes
uncontrolled movements
of the arms legs head
face and upper body
which is a hallmark
of huntington disease.
We will switch
now to another
catecholamine, and
that is noradrenaline.
In the brain,
neurons synthesizing
neuroadrenaline
have their cell
bodies primarily
in the locus
ceruleus and lateral
tegmental region
in the bones.
The locus ceruleus
neurons project
anteriorly to
large areas of the
cerebral cortex,
thalamus, hypothalamus,
and olfactory bulb,
with descending
projections to
the spinal cord.
The lateral tegmental
neurons have
ascending pathways
to the limbic system
and descending
projections to the
cerebellum and spinal
cord, with fibers
passing in the ventral
lateral column.
Noradrenergic pathways
involved in controlling
responses to
external sensory and
motor stimuli arousal
and attention and
learning and memory
and may be important in
major depression
midbrain neurons also
play important roles
in the control of
autonomic and neuroendocrine
functions magic
neurons just like
dopaminergic neurons
have high metabolic
demands and produce a
lot of reactive oxygen
radicals which makes
them very susceptible
for degeneration
therefore it's not
surprising that Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's
disease patients also
have the generation
of noradrenaline
-producing neurons.
These neurons also die
from chronic alcohol
***** and their loss
contributes to Wernick
-Corsakov syndrome.
Noradrenaline is also
synthesized outside
central nervous system,
primarily in the
adrenal medulla and
sympathetic nerves.
Another neurotransmitter
of this group
is serotonin, or 5
-hydroxytryptamine,
and it's mostly
present outside the
brain, such as platelets
and gut epithelium.
In fact, intestinal
epithelial cells
produce about 90%
of body serotonin.
5-Hydroxytryptamine
is also
neuromodulator in
the brain and it's
been implicated
in sleep and mood
disorders, depression
and anxiety.
Again, I encourage you
to learn key enzymes
for synthesis of
serotonin from tryptophan.
These are specific
for serotonin orgic
cells and the key
degradation pathways.
These are important
targets for treatment
of mood disorders.
These drugs increase
the levels of serotonin
in the synaptic
cleft by two
different mechanisms,
blocking the reuptake
of serotonin through
serotonin transporters
or by inhibiting
serotonin degradation.
Remember that
monoamine oxidase
inhibitors also increase
levels of
catecholamines, including
dopamine, norepinephrine,
and epinephrine.
Another key information
is that these
two classes of drugs
should never be
taken at the same time
or closed in time.
Since they act through
different mechanisms,
they can increase
serotonin to dangerous
levels and lead to
serotonin syndrome.
again this is caused
by medications that
build up high levels
of serotonin in the
body and too much
serotonin causes signs
and symptoms that can
range from shivering
and diarrhea to
muscle rigidity fever
and seizures and
serotonin syndrome
can cause that if not
treated so this is
a serious condition
and that is why it's
important not to
mix SSRIs with MAO
inhibitors and one
should be cautious when
switching between
these classes of drugs.
In the brain serotonin
is produced in
two small areas raffin
nuclei. Rosterone
nuclei projects widely
to the brain and
caudal has projections
to the spinal
cord these pathways
have broad influences
throughout the brain
and are important
for sensory processing
and homeostasis
they play a role in
psychotic behaviors
depression and obsessive
compulsive disorder
and eating behavior
and a major targets
for drugs used to
treat these diseases
Histamine is the last
neurotransmitter in
this group that we're
going to talk about
and is present in
large amounts in other
tissues such as skin
and lung but also
serves as neurotransmitter
in the brain.
Histaminergic neurons
primarily reside
in the posterior
hypothalamus
referred to as
tuberomammillary nucleus.
These neurons form long
ascending connections
to many telencephalic
areas, including
all areas of the
cerebral cortex, the
limbic system, basal
ganglia, and others.
Also, long-descending
neurons project
to mesencephalic and
brainstem structures,
including cranial
nerve nuclei,
substantia *****,
locus coeruleus,
mesopotamia tegumetum,
dorsal raphe,
cerebellum, and
spinal cord.
Hystaminergic
neurons play a major
role in arousal,
sleep-wake cycle,
in coupling
neuronal activity
with cerebral
metabolism, and
in neuroendocrine
regulation.
I would like to
show you this table
summarizing the key small
molecule transmitters
that we just talked
about, their site of
production, and
projections in the brain,
their functions and
associated disorders.
For instance, nigrostriatal
pathway consists
of dopaminergic
neurons residing in the
substantia ***** and
projecting to striatum.
Their major function
is control of
posture and movement,
and these neurons
degenerate in
Parkinson's disease.
Please use this table
in concert with cartoons
to learn where these
important clusters
of different neurons
are and to help you
organize your knowledge
about their locations
and their functions
this is essential
to understand because
to understand disorders
when these specific
areas of the brain
damaged whether it's the
degeneration or injury
or ****** now we will
talk briefly about
some other classes
of neurotransmitters.
ATP is an essential
molecule to store
energy but also
serves as a
neurotransmitter and
a danger signal that
can trigger
inflammatory response.
ATP and its metabolites
act on a system of
purinergic receptors
composed of P2X ionotropic
receptors and p2y
and p1 metabotropic
receptors so atp can act
as a fast neurotransmitter
and also together
with its metabolites
as a neuromodulator
these purines can be
released by both neurons
and astrocytes to drive
the pressure to sleep
and the main effect
of caffeine for
promoting wakefulness is
through inhibiting denosin
P1-class receptors.
Moving on to a
very different type
of neurotransmitter,
one that is
actually a gas, and
we already talked
about it earlier
in the session.
So, all of the
neurotransmitters that
we talked about
signal enter
greatly, And now we
are talking about a
neurotransmitter
that can also serve
as a retrograde
neurotransmitter.
Nitric oxide is
produced by nitric oxide
synthase, and it then
just diffuses in all
directions, including
from postsynaptic to
presynaptic terminal,
where it can modulate
the release of other
neurotransmitters, such
as glutamate. It also
diffuses to other
surrounding cells,
neurons and glia cells.
Nitric oxide can have
other physiological
effects, such as
relaxation of the smooth
musculature of intestines
and blood vessels.
Nitric oxide also
serves as a vasotilator.
Peptide neuron
transmitters are
chains of amino
acids that have
various effects
throughout the brain,
brain stem and
the spinal cord.
There are many, many
neuropeptides, and
here I mention only
a handful of them.
I would like you to
learn the members of
the opioid family
and their primary
receptors. They are
important mediators of the
pain pathways, and
the receptors are
targets of drugs that
are used to treat
chronic pain, as well
as recreational drugs.
Therefore, it
is important to
be familiar with
this system.
Please keep in mind
that neuropeptides
are usually derived
from precursor
proteins, so know
these precursor
proteins for these
key neuropeptides.
The second group
in this table lists
some hypothalamic
peptides, and we
will talk more about
their actions in a
separate session
about hypothalamus.
The last group
illustrates that many
neuropeptides that were
originally discovered as
hormones of the
gastrointestinal system are
also produced in the
brain where they have
many important modulatory
reactions on behaviors
such as feeding, blood
flow, pain, hormone
release and other
homeostatic functions.
So, in summary for
this session, there
are three main
concepts to learn.
First,
cells are
compartmentalizing
chemicals. They
process, store, and
then release them
for signaling.
The cell body
and release sites
can also be
very different.
Cells can be distributed
throughout the
brain and they
can also release
neurotransmitters throughout
the brain as well.
Or neuronal cell bodies
can be clustered in
nuclei where they produce
the neurotransmitters,
but then their
action can be either
diffused throughout the
brain or be specifically
targeted to certain
centers in the brain.
Neurotransmitter
receptors are the
main source of the
downstream effects,
and they are
really the control
point on how the
neurotransmitter
will change the
brain activity.
And lastly, I would
like you to know
the sites of
production and the
effects of the
neurotransmitters that we
talked about and
are listed below.
Please leave any
feedback on this
lecture at the
link listed here.
And thank you
for listening
and your attention.